time you cannot talk angry yeah so you
cannot no one can get you angry like
yeah but it depends sometimes you know
we're human beings you know like you
know for example Algeria I'm from
Morocco Algeria
and we're like we are full of love and
nurse but we still that's how we speak
all right it's too much
let me go home
but how are you today
you see now I'm gonna speak to you I'm
gonna
meet each other world war three yeah go
crazy
that's why people always have different
opinions but the one who probably know
better is the one who's fighting all his
life to understand exactly
anyway and I believe that God decides
when you have got inside you cannot get
angry as a Muslim no I mean even Jesus
got angry in the Bible remember Jesus
thank you very much remember Jesus
called called the his mother or woman no
no the first is we call them what he
compared them to the he called him the
son of the foreign
we're sorry
what sorry bro all right
pure victim mindset of these people it's
crazy they caused the problem and then
they and then they run away and cry and
spend the rest of the time
foreign
you know
and that's one of my way not speak to
Christians was to say I said when you
look to the Old Testament all through
the Old Testament always 1.1
Moses Abraham Noah Jacob Isaac Jeremiah
Daniel all of them came there's only one
God correct then what happened
we have Jesus According to some
Christians he said there's a free God
then who comes after Jesus
yeah no problem the father
Son and the Holy Spirit yeah then we
have Prophet Muhammad who came after he
said there's only one God so logically
speaking your false prophet
free
except that Jesus said he was God and
three God all of that he was of false
prophet but we don't accept that we said
Jesus even Jesus himself said there's
only one God however
Christianity with the sound
of God
no no I'll respect we don't use this
term Sunny because what is ambiguous
because English language Arabic language
even in your language when you say I
have a son you're gonna think I'm a
married man oh this person is my stepson
oh this person is younger than me that's
only my son you know we are the servant
of God we are the creation of God that's
why you know because imagine if you
imagine imagine have a cow I'll bring
you a cow and I'll bring you a chicken
and I said the chicken is a child of the
cow no it doesn't make any sense cow is
a cow and a chicken chicken
God is the Creator and the creation so
we're not the children of God we are the
Servants of God so where these words Son
of God came from
foreign
yes also there is to believe God has a
son for example Metro
they believe he was born on the 25th of
December and they believe it was the son
of God
it's paganism
to make it come to the Islamic teaching
it's simple there is only one God
foreign
say oh Muhammad Allah is one
Allah is a master's self-sufficient is
not in need of nothing everything is in
need of him
okay
Allah
has anger attribute anger attributes of
death attributes
Allah creates us and he chose people
amongst us he chose Abraham Moses
tell us how to worship God so as a
Muslim I believe all the Muslims we
believe the same thing if I was alive at
the time of the mighty messenger Jesus
is true Messiah and
Jesus come to me
in order for me to be safe I have to
follow Jesus teaching
because Jesus is Moses of course as many
yeah yeah all of them now the last
prophet is Muhammad
he came to teach us how to wash Allah
because Jesus teaching was specific for
that time specific for people likewise
Moses
for everyone you understand that's why I
think in the Bible
foreign
Jesus said there's a lot of stuff to
tell you but I cannot tell you right now
but the father who sent him to
conference
some Christians know that it is the holy
spirit but that's incorrect because when
Jesus was alive
or when he was on the earth the Holy
Spirit was with him
but he's talking about someone in the
future he will speak more in details
he spoke about God in depth about his
legislation about the day of judgment in
depth like if you go to the Old
Testament even the New Testament doesn't
speak about the day of judgment in
details doesn't doesn't speak about
David in details you know but Quran
speaks in details so what Jesus said it
applies to Prophet Muhammad I can't but
I cannot tell you right now how do you
change because okay there are a lot of
Bible it's true I believe that because
of translation sometimes not I won't say
that they change the world but they
misunderstood the translation so that's
why some people have different Bibles
everyone believe in whatever because
they didn't translate well every word
from the original Bible
you know we don't have original one we
have to understand because you want to
speak of the Bible the Bible did notice
not because of the translation okay I
believe that they are so Bible that they
modified
you know why you know why I've seen even
because
no no but even even a new testament to
make it clear to you yeah okay what
language Jesus spoke
[Music]
secondly the teacher of Jesus we have in
Greek yes
okay so now we have a language or
teaching of Jesus in Greek do we know
the translators who don't know them
if you don't know someone can you trust
him
no I don't know him
and trust you have to know you ask about
you a trustworthy in a true book by
investigate
don't know so how can we trust what they
said about Jesus is true that's one the
other thing also
you know it's manuscript
yeah
the manuscripts that we have in the New
Testament put the Old Testament aside
for the New Testament the earliest one
we have is like 400 years gap between
Jesus yeah there's a gap so basically to
make you understand someone came 400
years after Jesus and he started writing
which we have Matthew and Michael John
writing saying Jesus said this Jesus did
that and she said that we don't know him
the Bible the New Testament
the writers of the New Testament yes the
earliest manuscripts
this book was not given to you by
Matthew directly
this book is based upon something called
manuscripts manuscripts they're found in
the cave under the the Earth inside or
somewhere the earliest one we have
manuscript backdated the gap between
Jesus and the earliest New Testament
four ideas
after 400 years
to to write the Bible again now he can
give you truth it's true information
yeah so how can you trust him because we
don't know him so we don't know for
example if I said something in Arabic
yes
the sister can translate because you
know what you trust her she will
translate correctly but if you don't
know her you are not sure if what she's
going to translate is correct or not
okay so that's what is many problems
about the Bible when it comes to Quran
let's come to the Quran now you know
what the miracle of the Quran Allah made
it easy to be memorized Allah mentioned
the verse Allah said
no no we don't we don't follow
manuscripts we as a Muslims not like the
Christians and the Jews we don't go to
the caves
copies we don't like on memorialization
to make it clear to your Knuck If the
Jewish people yes no no if the Jewish
and the Christians and the Muslims all
of them decides to burn the scriptures
and say you know what let us burn the
Quran the Bible the Old Testament the
New Testament we should we should not
leave nothing in the written form the
only book
will be with us is the Quran because
it's in the heart
Ed will of Muslims memorized a wordful
way not the scholars we have Christians
no way I know I've been doing this for
10 years that can tell me like
everywhere without missing us in the
world word by word
no way there's no
when you come to the Muslims the Muslim
children the age of 9 and 10.
foreign
and teach it in the most
and we still have them the unknown to
call
chorus of Quran
that's why the Quran will never be lost
yeah that's what so before so it was
before you ask questions I want to
conclude with this that's why logic
dictates our logic dictate we should
worship God based upon a book that has
been preserved
not based upon a book that has been
corrupted
and the book that is being preserved
yeah that's it because God is the most
wise correct
no doubt the most wise will never leave
us with with with the truth mixed up
with the falsehood rather he will
clarify the truth to us and that is in
the Quran
you want to ask questions
is the last prophet of God
foreign
I mean
firstly the US
established
if we establish that Muhammad is a
prophet Allah yeah
dictate Allah will not choose a liar to
convey his message
Allah will choose truthful people honest
people
yeah he was I can give you many examples
from his life this person must be honest
person all right let me give one example
during his lifetime
his friend who is married to a woman
he loved us so much this woman yeah so
what happened this woman she won't
divorce
she left him she asked for divorce and
it's to follow her on the street okay
and the prophet Muhammad he said to his
to his other friends he said are you not
amazed how much he loves her and how
much she hates him
he went to her and he told her why don't
you go back to him
and remember she believes that he's a
message of Allah so she told him
are you telling me because Allah told
you that I have to go back to him or you
try to help us
if he was a liar where he would have
done he would say yes Allah told me so
go back to my friend why he said he said
no Allah never told me I'm trying to
Hope if you want to go back go back if
you don't if you don't want to go back
don't go back
there is no characteristics of a liar a
liar evil person especially someone
claims benefit to his friend because you
know he's going to use he's gonna
manipulate you know I'll give you
another one once the prophet Muhammad
you know eclipse
solar eclipse
Ibrahim passed away Ibrahim died
so his followers they saw eclipse
and they said the reason there's Eclipse
because the prophet Muhammad
passed away
if he was a lawyer remember a lawyer
will try to utilize anything to justify
his life you know in Opportunity he said
no
the eclipse that happened has nothing to
do with my son's life and no one is
death or life he's from God if you said
pray to God why did he never connect
himself to you he never collected people
to him he connected to who to God and
they never use that great event of
eclipse in his favor
foreign
I can give you many many once he was
going to the house someone invited him
he was going his friend was following
him so you know the door look to his
mannerism you know the door
the host opened the door the message of
Allah to them he's been following me
it's up to you you want to bring him in
or you can tell him to go back because
you never invite him if he was a liar he
would have said look my friend came to
me and a message of Allah you can
attempt to go back that's to come in no
he gave the option to the person he said
no so we can see during his life there
is many things he could have used
to manipulate the people but I never
used it you know why because he knows
Allah is watching him
if you live by the word of God you can
understand
even enemies they start calling the
trust where the truthful one
so if we accept that and we accept the
prophet Allah then and as the word Allah
the Quran mentions that Muhammad the
first Arabic and the beauty of Quran we
still recite the way it was reviewed
this is
Muhammad is not a father of your
interview Muhammad is Allah's messenger
in the servant Allah and the last
messenger that's one thing logically
speaking now now
is Allah's messenger all right one
question
depends where you from
Southeast
it depends where you are located the
Bible says
no the Bible is nothing about painful
yeah you know it says in the Bible
saying that he built the battle Yeah
it's not you don't have to pay his way
no no we have to face Mecca
Mecca which is from here Southeast
all right
and because Allah told us and that shows
you
the unit Unity of the source because
imagine you're from Romania I'm from
Algeria he's from Jamaica this person
all of us we prayed for the same
direction that feeling of unity
you see so Islam you know Islam pays
great attention to Unity
Unity of the souls Unity of the bodies
but in order to open the truth not just
for the sake of unity so for example
Islam will pray five times a day for a
man in the mosque so imagine you pay
five times a day
if you're working or you have to go
hospital so but let me show you the
beautiful stuff how you know
how to face
but I was gonna mention something yeah
before I go let me go back to the main
points about why Prophet Muhammad
is the last messenger from a rational
points of view yeah I'll tell you what
and this is just what our score is
mentioned the by the way not from my
head he mentioned every time Allah sends
another Prophet there's a reason there's
four reasons for Allah to send another
Prophet one of the reasons
the prophet Allah sent it was only for
that specific time
so Allah will send another Prophet
another time okay that's the first
reason second reason win the prophet's
teaching is being corrupted so Allah
will send another Prophet to clarify the
truth okay
so first one Prophet will send for
specific sign that's what Allah said
another Prophet second one the prophet
that came before his teaching was
corrupted allows and send another
Prophet to clarify the third one Allah
will send the prophet specific for
people
for specific people very Israelites yes
so Allah will send another Prophet to
different people yes the last reason
Allah will send the prophets another
prophets to Aid and to hope that Prophet
for example at that time of their sin or
Jesus and John yeah the prophet John yes
so all these four reasons are to send
the prophet Muhammad we can see the
Quran and the Sunnah is let me teach you
to preserve Prophet Muhammad was sent to
everyone Prophet Muhammad teaching his
wife all the times and if Allah wants to
send someone to Aid Prophet Muhammad he
would have sent it during his lifetime
he never did therefore logically
speaking that's why Prophet Muhammad
teaching is Allah Prophet also prophet
Muhammad's teaching
spread out around the world was too fast
you know the the before in in the year
after Prophet Muhammad passed away 40
years the Muslim empire Islamic empire
he was in the border of China Africa or
70 years maybe Africa and to Paris look
how I'll expect Islam you understand and
even now Islam is spread in the western
world
but what is happening now this is our
Prophet Muhammad told us so
there's groups we see people that
Muhammad is a true Messenger of Allah
because he told us about it with all the
Muslims there were only one group he
told us that will happen but he never
left left us without any clarification
he taught us what is the correct way he
said to follow his way and the way of
his companions
so that's why why Prophet Muhammad is a
lost Messenger as for the prayer praying
all together imagine we're going through
hardship when you come to the mosque I
wouldn't know I said how are you brother
and he said you know
come my brother come so Islam build good
Society Prophet Muhammad told us the
Muslim ummah is like one body if any
part of the body feel pain the rest of
the body feel pain Prophet Muhammad told
us
to the person who go to sleep and his
belly is full while his neighbor hungry
even if our neighbor is not a Muslim we
have to take care of him
we have to after him you're no doctor
and I know that Jesus we believe but
like I said let me explain to you I
believe I mean Jesus Paul
yeah I believe there's some truth in the
Bible no doubt because I believe in
Jesus Moses however I believe it's
corrupted yeah yeah
yeah but I believe it's corrupted by
Paul and by Constantine because both of
them had a vision and the both will
start talking about Jesus to be called
Trinity which doesn't make any sense
actually doesn't make any sense like the
father is good so we have one God
no the sun is good
but I'm gonna attack you a few minutes
yeah
we have to thank God for everything you
need
because
so if you say in the name of Allah is it
to bless it you know and that is on the
Old Testament in the Old Testament you
know Allah would to eat
and you're not allowed to eat other
things there's many things you know
allowed to eat in the Old Testament if
they change it because
but again did Jesus said that something
we can't really trust because what Jesus
also in the Bible said I didn't come to
abolish the law or the prophet I came to
fulfill it
not to go against it you know when the
young boy came to Jesus in John I'm just
using it show you you can see many
contradictions the young boy came to
Jesus he said or a good Master what
should I do to inherit the Kingdom of
Heaven meaning how can I get to Paradise
the young boy said to him I've been
doing it since I was young Jesus said to
him you are lucky in one thing the young
boy said to him what is it he said give
your wife away and follow me give you
what what follow me follow okay now we
can see it clearly Jesus
telling the young boy to keep what the
Torah come on what does he say so not
eat pork and to eat other things in the
stand so in Islam yes that's why Islam
yes there's things allowed to eat and
things will not allowed to eat because
logic dictates Allah is the creator of
everything so logically he knows what is
good for us in details
you know it's good for us in details
giving you something
remember God give you something and
telling you to say in the name of Allah
you have to listen to God and you want
to bless it is
I'm gonna do it again
so and now we say Bismillah
both
say to you
imagine your father bring you to the
house and he said you have to follow the
rules as a father he is the owner of the
house you follow the rules yeah
your father is not everything though but
Allah knows everything
allies always so whatever Allah told us
to stay away from is bad for us Allah
I can give you example you know Islam
Islam
um
Peter because the Bible said you know
we'll say to Peter what is distinguished
Islam will make Islam very special and
very unique in any religion listen to
this Capital yeah
five things
Islam came to preserve five things
Islam came to preserve the religion the
ones in Allah
that's why in Islam we're not allowed to
pledge Prophet Muhammad we're not
allowed to pray to anything we prayed
Allah directly yeah
Monica love it
reminded me so and now first they will
allow to pray to Prophet Muhammad
also we're not allowed to be Pagan taken
this is
forbidden now second one Islam second
Islamic Reserve intellect
is forbidden
yes thirdly Islam came to preserve
wealth
that's why gambling and interest is
forbidden
hopefully
Islam came to preserve life
sorry lineage
destroy the short societies yes
also Islam kept resolution families
that's what fornication adulteries
forbidden Islam came to preserve life
that's why killing people and Justice
and Community suicide is forbidden these
five things Islam came to preserve the
opposed of that
one is the blood of Jesus
but it's not like not drinking more like
because
scientifically prove enough someone can
Google it even small amounts of alcohol
is half of our body I don't believe the
almighty God would even allowed for us
alcohol because while alcohol is a very
harmful to us in the stand and you
believe
making wine no understand we don't
believe that no no we don't believe that
that's from the Greek Greek the Romans
they still like to drink too much so
they want to justify it
is
I can make
up for God yeah we don't believe that
and we don't believe that like I said
again those rights of the Bible it's
many things if it's like question
yourself and questioning day
trustworthiness you know but what we say
to you
don't say to Peter that's why you know
no doubt gambling interest fornication
all of that some people do benefit from
them who are they those who are in power
they make money from them that's why
majority of times those who are very
host such Islam
those who are in power because they look
at Islam as a threat for their business
they will go bankrupt so what they do
they use their money to make Islam look
bad through the mainstream media you
know even though is that yeah
lost things are happening
no no doubt but what I would say to you
look look I'll show you the hypocrisy of
the western media
do you know about the Christian soldiers
in in central Africa working the Muslims
you don't know because why the men
should never tell you a lot there is and
I don't believe every Christian as a
Muslim Allah teach me to be just there
is do you know about the Christians in
Brazil that they kill other Christians
that is but you never see them in the
mainstream media in the western world
but when it comes to Muslim one Muslim
stop someone in the cave in Algeria you
see in the left
a Muslim stop someone in the cave in
Algeria because they look for anything
to make Islam look bad but even that the
fastest
why you don't come to
say that this is
a messiah too
it's a messiah but what we say to you
look on Friday someone from Romania
became Muslim he's the third person
let's move that you know and the other
person is wrong so what we say to you
that um when it comes to Islam there's a
war against him but what is the first
growing religion in the western world
is spreading more
you know in Britain Islam inclining
they're going up Christianity is going
down
church are empty you know because Islam
especially agenda what's happening now
you know this eve agenda is pushing on
our children our families the only
religion that is standing firm against
it
we don't back down we don't play around
yes I like creative man woman chicken
rat there's no chicken right a chicken
mix this up in this then confusion you
understand so I would say to you Islamic
teaching how it goes in line with our
standards in our natural inclination of
course you want to worship God I wanna
worship God but how we're going to
worship God according to our desires
that's it and like I said to you how can
I follow a Bible a book that is being
translated firstly by people who don't
know them secondly those who wrote the
Bible we don't know them how can I trust
them when the Quran there's many
miracles one of the milk of the Quran
Peter Allah challenging people to bring
something like it
and no one is able to bring something
like the Quran in its eloquency
in its prophecies and it's legislation
language
for example let me mention something as
remember to show that Prophet Muhammad
who is not he was an honest person not a
liar did you know in the Quran there's a
chapter name after the mother of Jesus
called Mary
yeah
Allah speaking about the mother of Jesus
you know where
there were a lot of Jewish people in
Medina and the Jewish people in Medina
they believed Jesus was not a messiah
who was a false prophet and the prophet
Muhammad was there defending him
when we know he will not get no benefits
if he was a liar for defending Jesus in
Medina to Jewish people because if he's
a main target just to bring followers he
would have agreed with who with the
Jewish people
so I have no photo with yeah but what it
did
because it's perfect
can you chase perfect
that's good
that's good that's a good point because
some Muslims they like to fool their
coaches for example I'll give you
example which is widespread here here
some Muslims they force their daughters
to get married to someone yes
I'll give you a proof for that Prophet
Muhammad when he was alive
a woman came to him she said oh
messenger Allah my father put me married
to someone without asking me
foreign
you have a right to live
I don't want to live on a state but I
want people to know they should not
force their daughters to get married to
someone they don't like secondly we have
some Muslims when it comes to speaking
of Allah they speak about Allah
according to the Greek philosophy
why because they feel inferiority
complex they start using a Greek
philosophy to explain Allah's attributes
about Allah it happens to Christians as
well and the Jewish people so we can see
why they left not because they are
following because how do we know who's
following the truth who is not what
Muhammad told us that's why there's no
perfect afternoon because whoever We
need he has told us balaka said some
people they like to fool their desires
example let me give example how many
times you go to shop and they tell you
CCTV and cooperation
people still steal people still still
takes off another way even though it's
clear even though it's clear don't steal
You're Gonna Go prison is the problem
with the law the problem with the person
himself
do you understand
after this is a special guest you know
you are not special guest you've been
here many times
so you can leave it you don't know the
name yeah
keep coming
I know because you guys are 40 year old
man with a
skateboards
so what is the name of Allah
what is the name of Allah
so he just wants the attention he just
wants attention
[Music]
we have a chain of narration narrators
like we Allah and from someone brother
nor did he learned from some we know we
know each other we know their names
their biographies even with the
manuscript no doubt we have manuscript
they went different Haram
forbidden things yeah so we follow Islam
Islam is perfect Muslims are not perfect
yeah Islam is from God Muslims are human
beings they have desires they make
mistakes they understand so what let me
make something clear to you in Islam
Allah in the Quran I would say in Arabic
then I'll translate in English
for video to deal justly and kindly with
those who never fight against you for
example I have a Christian that is my
neighbor he never attacked me he never
tried to kill me Allah told me to be
nice to him and to be good to him
because he's lost
even even if he hates me imagine
you I can't go kill him because he hates
me I remember him
flap it on the face
I know it's too much
it's like someone coming to kill your
mother
try to be peaceful try to be peaceful
yes but Peter what we have to understand
the world we're living in sometimes you
have to fight defend yourself but try
your best to stay away try your best
protect yourself
that's what Allah said
when they were talking about turning
your face
if you forgive and Overlook that it's
good for you
[Laughter]
this is about if you see a Muslim
brother doing something you have to have
excuses for him seventh excuses
sometimes people have the excuses for
example maybe one day you're working you
are walking and you see me coming out of
a dumpling place
but maybe I'm just using the bathroom
so I need a bathroom or mine will go
quick to reactions
the full picture you're right 100 that's
what Islam teach us that you should not
straight away start guess what he's
judging people yeah so what would say to
you Peter yeah you know
Worship in God based upon a book that's
corrupted
that is this modified changed but the
Quran is clear it will be but then I'll
be a bit of contrary because in the
Bible just asking you to believe that
Jesus
to die for you for your thing
and I I could just stop there and say
okay I believe
my things and
[Music]
you know the story of Jesus that's our
sins that go against the Old Testament
is
that in the Old Testament
like opportunity you know opportunities
in the Old Testament even the New
Testament is not clear but in the Old
Testament if you commit sin you should
be responsible I commit saying I should
be responsible but in the Christianity
Jesus died for your sins
you believe Jesus died for your sins
Jesus died for our sins
no
no because in the Bible
my family thinks because of even my feet
probably before I baptized probably I
would say because only about is like
that what you you swear you say
okay Peter let me tell you let me help
you quickly
he said that
that's the problem
we cannot prove it I'm just saying no
problem
yeah yeah and we don't know them it's
not about someone we don't know them if
we know them they will trustworthy
truthful honest alhamdulillah we accept
honest truthful and we have a chain of
narration that met each other until
Jesus yes but we don't know them we
don't know the translators we don't know
manuscripts how come before the book
that's what Allah said why you why are
you following guesswork follow the truth
they only follow
guesswork only conjecture only
assumption okay so let's say
first how to become Muslim is to say
there's no one worthy of wash except
Allah and Muhammad is Allah
then the prayer okay so you show your
love of God
through the prayer okay then you give of
course step by step I'm just giving you
but when someone become Muslim we take
it step by step everything you have to
do everything you know because at the
end of the day we are human beings you
know we we take it step by step so the
prayer that
fasting is very beneficial for us for us
for the environment for the people okay
likewise prayer is good for you also
charity how many times you have people
say why there's a poverty in Islam there
is a solution which called
zakat charity
there's the cat and
discussion about like let's say you see
someone on the street
or something and he's asking for money
sometimes in your mind is thinking but
he's young he doesn't work
that these people smoking crack smoking
drugs so why do I say this and do you
need food I don't know that it's not my
job that's why I do no no but I go to
them I said you need food
if he says yes or buying food do you
need that clothes or something I see you
I don't see if it needs money I'll give
you money and I'll tell you I'm gonna
give you money I don't know situation
but if you're gonna buy drugs with it
then you're gonna be before good
I'm gonna help you I'll try my best I'm
not the best example to follow but I'll
try my best but when you come to Islam
charity there's two type there is
Charity which you have to give to the
poor you have to there's a charity which
is is voluntary you give you but which
record is the cattle man which is to pay
to give a charity from your wealth 2.5
I'm from us 2.5 you have to give it to
the poor ones to not just support even
traveler someone is traveling and it
doesn't have enough money so you help
them
so in Islam how do we go to paradise
firstly
by the mercy of Allah
Muhammad he said everyone those who
deserve to go Paradise they will go with
the mercy of Allah
even you he said even me I will enter
the mercy of Allah because yes we do
good deeds but one of the worst thing
one of the worst since
God no there's narration on the day of
judgments
be humble to God because regardless how
much we worship God we wash Allah we
will never be able to pay back Allah for
His blessings even your eyes there's a
narration on a day of judgment I would
say to the angels take my servant to
Paradise because of my Mercy the servant
will say no Allah because of my good
deeds I've been worshiping you for 80
years Allah will say bring him back take
the blessings of his eyes put on a scale
and puts his good works on the other
scale the blessing of the eyes is more
heavier he said well you done doesn't
even equal to the blessings of the eyes
let alone the other blessings so his
Allah said take him to Hell Fire because
of his Good Deeds he said no no Allah I
want Paradise because of your mercy so
Allah teaches us what regardless how
much you wash Allah always be humble and
don't look down on people
you know don't look down people because
looking down is a sin as well you know
because you never know Islam you can
leave it Christianity is about church we
Church you know Islam is not just for
you and me even for the government yes
it's a lifestyle a way of life it's for
you and the government
you have to implement it you know
because when you implement the teaching
of God you have good Society you have a
less crime looking now stubborn nice
yeah nice now you know crazy you know
because why we turn away from God but
when you I was watching with my wife you
know this man he tortured up in 2021
illusion on new cross so these two guys
they got two students they tortured them
in New Clothes burn them yes
and they killed him you know how much
they give the guy they gave him like 25
years or 35 years the police officer he
said I had to go back try to get him
alive but even get him Alive prison here
is a joke
prison here is like Hotel you got food
you go to education you go I'm not
promoting the prison yeah don't go
prison Brothers okay you know the job
they give you a job as well you know
sometimes it's better than outside but
not to be abused
humbled and they won't I mean
yeah we have to be realistic yes
creating to be all perfect if you are
all perfect
no the problem the problem with this
prison system is not helping the
problems
it's like it's not resolving the
problems but God's teaching if you steal
something something which is valuable
then your hand will be gone bye bye to
your hand if you know that you're not
still no no no no but if I know I'm
gonna rope someone they're gonna put me
in prison for six months and they're
gonna give me a job food I love it
manush TV you know
that's what Allah taught us in the Quran
Allah said Allah's capital punishment it
gives your life what how you give us a
life if it's a capital punishment
because I know if I'm going to kill you
I'll be killed I said no no no no no
so I saved two lives I save your life
and my life look at the Islamic
registration that's why majority of
people that hate Islamic capital
punishment either that ignorant or
themselves are criminals that's what
happens
between Islam there is a punishment for
the criminals okay in the western world
that we call it Sharia have you heard
the word Sharia
I'm in the Divine love yeah Divine Law
like taking care of your parents is a
Sharia but yes
aspect of saying are called capital
punishment those capital punishment is
for the evil criminals okay two as a
deterrence you know it's determined
the church get them away do not do evil
okay for example if I know if I kill you
or be killed I'll be scared for my life
but the government
okay
we have a lot of Islam if you steal they
will cut your hands so so you are ahead
nobody wants to know his day let the
government
they are not applying anymore this loud
because of the right of human that's
what that's not the right of him but
anyway this is a joke
because the right of him if I kill you
they should kill me Muslims they should
kill me if I can even if you are not
used
to deserve that but yeah still who are
we to decide with him
we are following what God say for us
[Laughter]
[Music]
if if you kill him they will kill you so
you will you will not be able to kill
him
exactly you will take his life
the families can forgive you if they see
you okay maybe you're very very
important or something like that yeah
even imagine now you did it
intentionally but however you are very
angry you can't you just got so angry
yes then the family can forgive you and
Allah told us to forgive however if you
an evil person you're doing it too as a
joke yes yes as an accident no you know
you don't get killed no you understand
so and that is in the Old Testament by
the way
why there's too many crimes
because the punishment is too strong
thank you very much no one is afraid of
punishment but what I would tell you
Peter to focus on the most important
thing is the ones of course
that worship God Alone
this teaching that's what advice
worshiping God alone and that will never
find in the Bible because the Bible
let's go through Jesus again put the
Bible aside like we said we don't know
we cannot trust it so why you want to
stick to a book we cannot trust when we
have a book it's a clear miracle clear
past clear teaching
babies
you know how to become Muslim you know
what to say I don't know okay I'll tell
you Allah he said and you're going to
become Muslim you have our brothers here
okay okay
Allah
Allah in English
there is nothing
worthy of worship
yeah in truth in
Allah and
I
bear
that witness
is the last messenger
and the servant of Allah
and Jesus
is a servant and the messenger
foreign